à valréas à partir de 20h35 une
dramatique sur l'a3 qui vous est
proposée par fr3 nord pas de calais
picardie série noire au carnaval c'est
une une dramatique donc vous vous
reconnaîtrez dans les principaux rôles
jacques bonnaffé ainsi que ronny
coutteure et fred personne à 22h35 après
le journal soir 3 un nouveau conte
d'italie et nous terminerons notre
soirée en musique avec prélude à la nuit
l'émission proposée et présentée par
charles humbert ce soir la mort d'isolde
une pièce pour piano de liszt et wagner
je n'ai juste une me reste effectivement
plus le temps de vous dire que demain
c'est patricia poirier qui vous tiendra
compagnie en ce 15 août place à
l'information
bonsoir